I feel like at this point with these
taste tests every time someone tells me
to mystery me I'm expecting like balls
it's possible I've never had a shin food
before I don't really know what it's
going to taste like maybe tropical
Caribbean
I am a Haitian virgin right look how
cute this is oh my god that's really
good
sign me up give me all of that yes he's
very smoking with like awesome by smeet
going on not spicy it's just great it's
flavorful
so money how could you not like this is
just puff pastry and mean
that is not what I expected from goat
meat I feel like I can taste what it
last ate and I'm not okay with that if
you have goat cheese with is that like
sick and wrong this is tender it's
flavorful
oh it's my new favorite meat
it's juicy I like is it fried anything
fried is great
we got tender there's this it's so
tender I could eat this every day and
just be like fine I'm sorry mom but I
wish I could cook like I really do
oh that smells so good and it's not
really yeah like it's not too chewy
either though very well seasoned very
well spiced I'm a big fan couldn't taste
the conch though you say it the whole
thing at once
there's the spine this is how a fish
should be prepared you know we shouldn't
like take all the thought of it I mean
the bones are like easy enough to pick
out if a little inconvenient you get
stabbed with a bone once you don't you
don't get stabbed with a bone twice I'm
a carnivore I feel like oh well I
thought it was I thought there's no
bones and there was one did there
there's not a whole lot done to the fish
in terms of seasoning it's good mmm
thank you for that so many flavors it's
like if banana bread were covered in
sugar I don't like the word moist but
like it is always like a good voice you
can hear like the yeah I got the clean
plate award though mm-hmm
I think Asian food I didn't know that
there's this amazing delicious flavor
profile just waiting for me it's very
rarely you go through at Asus and you
think everything is awesome but
seriously every autumn is cesarean it
take me to Haiti now yes this is amazing
I want all of it because it's what
everybody loves now it's time you take a
nap well I have a huge mouth and very
low standards in terms of how I look on
camera